hola que tal bienvenidos a este programa
especial de france 24 sobre el año 2021
desde mexico el tema central será la
migración en el país el instituto
nacional de inmigración ha detectado el
triple de indocumentados que el año
anterior en eeuu la autoridad reportó
haber encontrado a más de millón y medio
de personas en tránsito sin documentos
ello a pesar del despliegue de tropas de
la guardia nacional que ha dispuesto
andrés manuel lópez obrador tanto al
norte como al sur para impedirles el
paso ante las críticas de que la medida
responde a directrices de washington el
presidente mexicano argumenta que busca
salvaguardar la propia soberanía y a la
vez proteger a los migrantes mientras
los políticos imponen normas para
controlar la migración muchas de las
personas que buscan mejor vida están
parando en mexico para descansar y
seguir su camino otras en cambio no
continuarán y han decidido que desde
ahora este será su hogar
le di mi hernández suyo de honduras hace
un mes las pocas opciones de tener un
empleo fijo y las amenazas de extorsión
por parte de las pandillas no le dejaron
una opción ahora se encuentra en ciudad
de méxico
yo estaba saliendo de mi trabajo a las
12 del mediodía cuando se me acercaron
22 tipos y
me pusieron unos cuchillos y me dijeron
que tenía que darle lo que yo había
ganado
la travesía para llegar duró 15 días
algunos en autobús y varios a pie por
caminos inhóspitos iván tuvo peligros en
el camino
incluso una vez en chiapas 2 iba
siguiendo un vehículo sospechoso y los
todo que
meterlos a entrenarlos en la celda
verdad en el bosque para que no nos
vieran porque no los dejaban
hoy lady quiere encontrar empleo aquí
así como otros 49 inmigrantes en su
mayoría hondureños y haitianos que se
encuentran seguros en casa otro chan uno
de los cinco albergues que hay en la
capital mexicana
gabriela hernández directora del
albergue les ofrece techo comida apoyo
psicológico y actividades de integración
a su juicio hoy la capital del país está
concentrando un mayor número de
migrantes por las políticas erróneas
el que la guardia nacional esté
correteando migrantes en tapachula hace
que ellos tengan que venir a buscar
mejores oportunidades
méxico se está convirtiendo en el tapón
para lo que no pasa ningún migrante y
esto repercute en las ciudades grandes
no lópez obrador se rehúsa a que el país
sea un campamento de inmigrantes pero
con la reactivación del programa quédate
en mexico se está viendo obligado a
recibir a los solicitantes de asilo que
envía estados unidos mientras refugios
como casa tachán están y seguirán sobre
poblados
no hemos podido
estar como con el número mínimo que
podemos atender porque la demanda es
grande porque las autoridades se empeñan
en no querer abrir un
y albergue emergente aunque la mayoría
de los migrantes llegan a mexico como
tránsito hacia eeuu otros consiguen
oportunidades y se quedan es el caso de
josé iván gonzález
y yo decía así encuentro trabajo me
quedo trabajando
y gracias a dios me dieron la
oportunidad de aquí y estoy trabajando
me gustaría seguir trabajando para
ahorrar y traer a mi familia mis tres
hijos cuya esposa iván y lerín se
quedarán en mexico como muchos migrantes
mientras consigan empleo no piensan
seguir a eeuu y si lo intentarán la
política de contención de lópez obrador
les impediría cruzar la frontera al
final su permanencia es un revés a lo
que esperaba el gobierno mexicano la
comisión mexicana de ayuda a refugiados
recibió de enero a octubre más de 108
mil peticiones de asilo de inmigrantes
una cifra sin precedente
el presidente de lópez obrador insiste
en resolver las causas que provocan la
migración y para ello impulsa aplicar en
centroamérica su programa de siembra de
árboles como una opción de empleo la
realidad es que mientras ello ocurre
muchos migrantes ya no tienen el sueño
americano sino el sueño mexicano un reto
de grandes